oui pour en débattre nous sommes avec
julie garnier porte parole de la france
insoumise bonsoir julie garnier merci
d'être avec nous à vos côté nadia rayman
à fondatrice de l'association la brigade
des mers bonsoir à nadia rayman nahar et
maintenant merci d'être avec nous alors
ce n'est pas un texte contre les
religions ni contre la religion
musulmane a martelé le premier ministre
il est quand même question
d'interdiction de certificat de
virginité de renforcement de la lutte
contre la polygamie et les mariages
forcés
ça y ressemble quand même un tout petit
peu jauni garnier selon vous alors cette
loi elle s'appelle maintenant la loi de
renforcement des principes républicains
sauf que en fait cette loi ne va
renforcer aucun principe ne va pas
renforcer la liberté ni légalité ni la
fraternité parce que déjà pour la
liberté
on voit déjà que son article 18 va
reprendre grandement l'article 24 qu'on
voyait déjà dans la loi sécurité globale
et sur laquelle on avait énormément
d'inquiétude et les associations partage
ces inquiétudes là dessus notamment sur
les possibilités ouvertes de dissolution
qui reste très flou ça va également
envers l'égalité
parce que il n'ya pas un seul mot par
exemple sur le séparatisme des riches
vous le savez dans cette loi qui a été à
l'initiative comptez 50 cet article elle
n'en compte plus que 51 parce que dedans
ils ont notamment retirer l'obligation
de mixité dans les logements sociaux
voilà donc le combat aussi elle ne va
pas vers l'égalité elle ne va pas vers
la fraternité parce qu'il va ça va
encore déchaîné une vague hostile envers
les musulmans avec des bavardages
inutiles et imprécis et ô combien
dangereux quant à la laïcité je vous le
dis cette loi et même une attaque contre
la loi de 1905 est alors qu'il se
réclamer d'une filiation puisqu'ils ont
choisi la date anniversaire avec la loi
du 9 décembre 1905
en fait on va voir que ça va même à
l'encontre de principe qui avait été
actée à ce moment là je ne prends que
comme exemple le fait de pouvoir
permettre aux églises de pouvoir
bénéficier de biens de rapports aidant
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui les églises
elles sont financées uniquement grâce
aux fidèles de ce ne sera plus le cas
les églises pourront être financées en
achetant par exemple des biens ayant
vivant de ses biens ce qui veut dire que
vous pourriez avoir des églises cents
fidèles mais qui pourront être très
florissante
ils sont en train d'inventer la start-up
église voilà ce que font ces apprentis
sorciers avec la loi de 1905 et
redoutent que ça soit l'objectif premier
est effectivement le premier ministre
qui dit je le cite que c'est un texte
garantissant qu'aucune religion ne
puisse être au dessus des lois c'est une
loi clairement contre le fondamentalisme
religieux elle était nécessaire selon
vous nadia est manal correspond à une
attente
alors moi je pense que la loi il ya déjà
une loi il ya la loi 1905 déjà qui
existent déjà je pense qu'à chaque fois
où sortent des lois sur des lois je
pense qu'il faut déjà appliquer les lois
qui existent dans notre pays
déjà alors j'ai lu j'ai vu dans le texte
avait effectivement le certificats
médicaux laisser les mariages forcés et
tout ça ça c'est de toute façon les
mariages forcés ce n'est pas avec une
loi qu'on va les interdire c'est pas en
auditionnant entre guillemets de minutes
un couple où la jeune fille va être
terrorisé par la famille et tout ça bien
sûr qu'on va la préparer
on va voir je sais pas comment ils vont
détecter parce que ça existe déjà par
rapport pour les mariages blancs ont
fait cinq minutes pour voir si c'est
vraiment pas un mariage blanc pour un
mariage blanc si c'est je pense que tout
ça tout ce qui nous a coupé dans ce test
y'a rien de ça existe déjà et je pense
qu'il faut déjà appliquer la loi
je vous dis revenir ce qui a été dit
tout à l'heure madame concernant sa
liste des musulmans effectivement j'ai
entendu beaucoup la france est soumise
disent que ça saute touche les musulmans
moi personnellement en tant que
travailleuse sociale et membre de la
section la brigade des mers je pense que
les musulmans n'ont plus besoin de la
france soumise pour nous dire qu'on est
touché ou pas je pense que les musulmans
il n'y a pas que des musulmans en france
et quand il ya une loi c'est pour tout
le monde y a des
cueilli à des chrétiens il ya des athées
tout ça on peut pas dire que cette loi
et pour les musulmans c'est là que l'on
remonte la haine et c'est là qu'on va
pas s'en sortir ou dans les quartiers
que si à chaque fois on dit qu'il ya une
loi qui est créée on dit c'est contre
les musulmans contre les cathos contre
les athées on va pas s'en sortir nous
qui ont comme sur les quartiers qui
essayons de sortir cette jeunesse qui
effectivement est sûre plus la
victimisation que de respect de
certaines lois
alors pour moi c'est pas une loi par
exemple dans les quartiers qu'on a
besoin si on veut vraiment se sortir par
rapport à se rallier à cet intégriste
religieux et tout ça pense qu'il faut
déjà appliqué ce qui existait et je
pense qu'il faut arrêter à alimenter la
haine des musulmans n'ont pas besoin
encore de discours de haine de l'autre
côté je pense que vous madame vous êtes
aiguë votre première mission avant tout
c'est justement entre vous pouvez dire
ce que vous voulez mais quand vous dites
des choses comme ça à la télé et j'ai
entendu tout à l'heure monsieur
mélenchon on parlait même mana pardon de
vous couper et je vais vous laisser
finir votre propos mais mais justement
va écouter précisément pour que les
téléspectateurs comprennent bien ce qu'a
dit jean luc mélenchon le texte proposé
à des intentions de stigmatisation des
musulmans et prétend organiser la
religion musulmane comme napoléon l'a
fait pour les chrétiens ce texte a des
caractéristiques concordataire qui ne
sont pas acceptables
alors on va laisser la parole à gilles
garnier avant de vous faire rebondir
nouveau nayarit maintenant puisque vous
ne semblez pas d'accord sur ce point
précis julie garnier
déjà je voulais revenir sur un point
c'est que si cette loi avait pour
objectif d'empêcher des attentats comme
il s'est passé avec samuel pâtit vous
savez très bien que cette loi n'aura
aucun effet là dessus je rejoins tout à
fait ce que disait mas d'armand et
menaces sur la dessus ce qu'il faut
c'est des moyens or on est encore dans
une communication
mais là où il faut être précis et madame
c'est que si à monthois défend de la
l'excité vous savez très bien que la
laïcité elle doit l'être comme un bloc
alors vous ne pouvez pas tolérer qu'on
ne parle pas dans cette loi qui se veut
comme la descendante finalement de la
loi de 1905
vous ne pouvez pas tolérer qu'on ne
parle pas alors du concorde
qui est en alsace moral on ne parle pas
et vous savez qu'aujourd'hui en france
il ya des collectivités territoriales
qui paient des prêtres qui salarient des
prêtres en guyane ça pourquoi est ce
qu'on n'en parle pas pourquoi est ce
qu'on ne parle pas des financement des
lieux de culte qui sont faits par des
élus et qui est autorisé depuis la loi
de 1942 qui a été remise par pétain
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne revient pas
dessus pourquoi est ce qu'on ne revient
pas sur ces faits qui existe et
malheureusement si on devait traiter de
la question de la laïcité
il faut la traiter comme un bloc et
c'est pour ça que nous disons que
malheureusement c'est quoi vise encore
uniquement une religion les huiles par
deux énormes et j'ai c'est intéressant
ce qu'on vous nous dites le premier
ministre présentait d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui comme une loi qui veut
lutter contre l'islamisme radical alors
c'est vrai qu'on ne parle ni de
séparatisme ni de communautarisme dans
ce texte mais enfin c'est vrai que voilà
c'est peut-être hypocrite c'est
peut-être ce que vous dénoncez
d'ailleurs mais tout le monde sait que
voilà c'est l'islamisme radical qui est
parfaitement visé j'ai envie de venir
personne ne s'engage réellement c'est
bien ça le problème justement c'est que
le problème c'est que ces gens-là ne
défend pas la laïcité
ils sont là uniquement pour stigmatiser
encore une religion et c'est bien
dommage parce que la laïcité elle il
faut qu'on se batte pour elle que la loi
de 1905 n'est pas arrivé comme ça par
hasard il y a un vrai combat à mener et
dans ce combat sur la laïcité nous avons
des propositions concrètes à faire
le problème c'est que ce sont eux qui
stigmatise et nous avons des
propositions bien plus large la laïcité
ne doit pas être un prétexte
et aujourd'hui c'est de cela dont il se
sert et ses dents ça qu'ils sont
hypocrites et nous ne le sommes pas
nadia rehman a justement là pour le
gouvernement s'y prend mal ya une forme
d'hypocrisie faudrait nommer les choses
finalement et ça passerait peut-être
mieux c'est aussi votre avis alors je
mens c'est aussi mon avis je suis tout à
fait d'accord ils sont toujours pas le
courage de dire effectivement on parle
effectivement de l'islamisme nous ça
veut dire la religion musulmane
effectivement par rapport à tous les
importants qu'on a vécu est
malheureusement à l'atroce attentat de
la décapitation de monsieur samuel pâtit
moi je dis qu'effectivement il faut
nommer les choses c'est juste justement
en faisant semblant de nommer surnommé
tourner autour du pot qu'on a justement
c'est attendant cette jeunesse qui a un
peu perdu alors moi je dis effectivement
cette loi et fait effectivement pour
j'aime pas le mot stigmatisation baptisé
parce que c'est pas stigmatiser il faut
nommer les choses on a un problème
aujourd'hui avec l'islam radical qu'on
le veuille ou non il faut nommer ceux
d'essence
on a eu énormément de jeunes qui sont
partis en syrie dans les quartiers on a
de plus en plus de jeunes qui sont
enfermés que dans la religion n'ont
aucun discours moi qui peux vous dire
qu'il suit dans les quartiers et puis
certains des élus aussi de la france à
soumission dans le quartier il faut
arrêter vous aussi de jouer de dire que
de se battre toujours en utilisant
stigmatiser on stigmatise personne ont
dénoncé justement si on ne dit pas les
choses on n'a pas le courage de dire oui
il faut qu'on soit plus dure avec un
certain une religion qui aujourd'hui
imposent leurs lois particulièrement
dans les quartiers ailleurs vous donner
raison à ces islamistes radicaux qui
alimentent la haine et nous les femmes
comme moi et plein d'autres on va subir
ont déjà il ya des certaines femmes qui
subissent créez-vous la france est
soumise
vous soutenez ce monsieur ces gens qui
sont dans les quartiers vous voyez
entendirent serment dans les quartiers
non mais vous êtes comme moi dans les
quartiers il ya la france a soumis ce
qui est dans les quartiers vous voyez
comme moi des jeunes filles et fillettes
voilées
vous voyez comme moi que les cartes et
de plus en plus on voit que de jeunes
couples
on voit on voit effectivement cet islam
radical 7 et politiques des grands
frères qui a pris les quartiers c'est
une femme de gauche madame qui vous
parle
moi j'ai raté la froide insoumise jeu
les rater excusez moi parce que je suis
sur mon téléphone gerald j'ai quitté la
france est soumise à cause de ça j'ai
soutenu clémentine aux opca à cause de
ça alors aujourd'hui je peux vous dire
que il faut arrêter de nous mettre dans
dans l'embarras quoi julie garnier
qu'est ce que vous répondez parce que
c'est vrai que ce sont 2
visions qui s'affrontent ce sont des
arguments qui voit là qu'on retrouve
souvent alain confronté à l'autre moi ce
que je regrette en fait c'est qu'elle ne
voit pas et ne prennent pas plus de
hauteur en fait dans son analyse
le vrai problème du séparatisme
aujourd'hui c'est que dans les écoles
il n'y a plus de mixité sociale sur le
sur le terrain il n'y a plus de mixité
non mesdames je faisais pas dire au
talon madame quand j'étais pas d'accord
avec vous mais j'en ai pas interrompu ce
que je veux dire c'est que il n'ya pas
de mixité s'il y un séparatisme
aujourd'hui il est entretenu en premier
lieu parce qu'ils sont allés le dis si
aujourd'hui il n'y a livré ségrégation
spatiale
oui il y a des communes sur lesquelles
qui se fiche complètement des quotas de
logements sociaux
il y a des communes où il n'y a plus
d'école en france 500 en tout 500
communes sans école aujourd'hui ce qu'on
constate c'est que là où on fait reculer
les services publics tout ce qui fait
lien tout ce qui fait sens dans la
république
alors vous augmentez toutes les fissures
oui ça sera pour certains endroits de
l'islamisme dans d'autres ça sera
l'intolérance le racisme le front
national
l'extrême droite et c'est à chaque fois
qu'on fait reculer la république alors
ce sont les toutous les séparatistes
dans tous les sens qui progresse et donc
oui c'est moi je ne reconnais qu'une
seule communauté la communauté de la
république la communauté de la nation et
c'est celle ci aujourd'hui qui est
malmené c'est celle ci aujourd'hui qui
fait fermer des lits d'hôpitaux c'est
celle ci qui aujourd'hui est en train de
vendre nos biens communs
aujourd'hui on est en train de vendre
encore une partie d'edf mais on n'en
parlent pas ils le font par derrière
aujourd'hui on est en train de demander
encore des efforts pour demain avec la
réforme des retraites aujourd'hui on a
un gouvernement qui ferment les yeux sur
les violences policières ses salariés au
lieu d'art et la réalité d'aujourd'hui
ils sont en train ce sont eux qui sont
en train d'organiser le véritable
séparatisme aujourd'hui on n'a plus
jamais que besoins de notre république
de tous nos services publics et ils sont
en train de reculer d'être appauvri
d'être malmenés c'est ça notre premier
combat et c'est ça être de gauche
être de gauche c'est défendre nos biens
communs défendre la république et c'est
exactement ce qu'ils sont en train
d'attaquer aujourd'hui le mot de la fin
pour vous n'alliez arrêt magna alors moi
tu peux vous dire que le discours on
l'entend depuis des années de toute
façon la france a soumis
à gauche aussi c'était à contribuer à
tout justement ghettoïser les gens et
tout ça ils ont rien fait moi j'ai
travaillé dans des villes de gauche où
s'étaient des maires de gauche des
députés de gauche
ils ont rien fait je suis désolé c'est
que de là c'est que de discours c'est
que de la com de com vous êtes
politiquement je ne suis pas une
politique je suis une femme que de
terrain je peux vous dire mais je peux
vous dire quelque chose madame que votre
discours justement on ça fait des années
qu'on l'entend aujourd'hui il faut
nommer les choses pourquoi parce que
nous avons une jeunesse à protéger et
tant que vous serez dans l'opposition
que nous inquiète discours que politique
c'est que de la communication
et moi je vous connais des villes que de
gauche qui j'ai travaillé que dans des
villes de gauche et je peux vous dire
madame les choses se sont faites
justement par la gauche cette gosse à
qui on a fait confiance
eh ben on s'est retrouvé avec des
intégristes religieux avec l'histoire
des grands frères dont la droite aussi à
participer ya pas que la gauche vous
avez fermé les yeux par intérêt
électoral râler à tremblay en france
n'ont jamais eu droit aux raiders halte
à sevran allée à tremblay en france vous
êtes bien ça fait 30 ans que la tremblay
en france et par la france a soumis
regardez ce qu'il vous dit tremblay
regarde d'oeuvre en regard du jeu
regardez les villes où c'est repris par
la france soumise depuis des années par
la gauche 6 7 6 6 et la pharmacie on ne
vous met pas d'accord mais là mais on a
compris vos deux messages et vos deux
visions opposées en tout cas ça nourrit
le débat remercie julie garnier par
parole la france a soumises et nadia
ray-ban la fondatrice de l'association
la brigade des mers merci à vous